ÿ
>>> SO, WE CELEBRATE NEW YEAR'S
EVE TOGETHER.
WE'RE BOTH DADS.
TONIGHT ANDY COHEN IS HERE TO
TALK WITH ME.
"THE DADDY DIARIES: THE YEAR I ;
a
GREW UP" IS NOW OUT.
IT IS NUMBER THREE ON "THE NEW ;
a
CONGRATULATIONS, ANDY COHEN.
>> THANK YOU, ANDERSON COOPER.
MY FEET ARE DNGLING OFF THIS ;
a
CHAIR.
>> YOU CAN JUST LATCH THEM ONTO
THE THING.
YOUR BOOK -- I'M PROBABLY ONE O;
a
THE FEW PEOPLE INTERVIEWING YOU;
THAT'S ACTUALLY READ YOUR BOOK
BY THE WAY.
>> I DID DO A RANT ON THE RADIO
TODAY.
IT IS AMAZING HOW MANY -- EVEN ;
a
PRODUCERS DON'T READ THE BOOK.
BUT THANK YOU FOR READING MY ;
a
BOOK.
AND I KNOW HOW MUCH YOU LOVED ;
a
.
>> I DID.
>> YES.
>> IT'S REALLY FUNNY.
BUT YOUR BOOK BEGINS SKPENDS --
I REALLY JUST READ THE PARTS I'M
IN.
>> YOU'RE IN IT A LOT.
>> IT BEGINS NEW YEAR'S EVE AND
ENDS WITH US NEW YEAR'S EVE THIS
YEAR.
I JUST WANT TO REPLAY FOR OUR
VIEWERS WHO MAY HAVE FORGOTTEN ;
a
BEGAN.
YES.
>> JANUARY 1, 2022.
IT WAS ABOUT FIVE MINUTES INTO
THE NEW YEAR.
>> RIGHT.
AND THIS WAS YOUR RANT ABOUT
MAYOR de BLASIO AT THE TIME.
>> YES.
>> AND IN THE BOOK, YOU WRITE
ABOUT HOW IT ENDED UP IN A
SPIRAL OF SELF DOUBT FOR THE
NEXT WEEK.
LET'S JUST PLAY THIS MOMENT.;
a
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.;
>> OH, PLEASE, TELL US
SOMETHING, ANDY.
>> WATCHING MAYOR de BLASIO -- ;
a
>> DON'T GO ON A RANT.
>> -- DO HIS VICTORY LAP DANCE ;
a
CRAPPIEST -- AS THE MAYOR OF NE;
AGREE ON IS WHAT A HORRIBLE ;
a
.
>> WOW.
>> SO, SAYONARA SUCKA.
2022.
IT'S A NEW YEAR.
BECAUSE GUESS WHAT?
I HAVE A FEELING I'M GOING TO B;
a
STANDING RIGHT HERE NEXT YEAR.;
?
DANCING AS THE CITY -- YOU.;
a
>> HOW ABOUT THAT I HAD NO
VOICE.
>> I LOVE THAT YOUR VOICE --
>> TEQUILA.
I AM LIKE AN ANGRY CAB
.
>> BUT IT'S INTERESTING IN YOUR
BOOK TO READ HOW -- I MEAN, THA;
a
BEGINNING OF THAT YEAR, AND IT
DID START THIS SHORT OF SHAME,
LIKE YOU --
>> YOU THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT AT
FIRST.
>> YES.
>> THEN THE NEXT MORNING A
FRIEND REACHES OUT AND IS LIKE,
HEY, EVERYTHING OKAY?
THAT WAS YOUR FIRST INKLING. ;
a
>> WHY WOULDN'T EVERYTHING BE
OKAY?
THEN I LEFT MY HOUSE AND I WAS
GETTING POUNDED OUT, YOU KNOW, ;
a
LIKE THIS, YOU KNOW, FIST BUMPS;
CITY.
I WAS LIKE, OH, I HAVE DONE
SOMETHING GOOD.
THIS WAS WONDERFUL.
BUT THAT WAS -- THE BOOK IS A ;
a
YEAR IN MY LIFE AND BEGINS THEN;
AND ENDS WITH US -- AND YOU SEE;
a
>> YOU SEE THAT AS SYMBOLIC OF
WHERE YOU ARE NOW?
>> I DO
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE YEAR I HAD
A SECOND CHILD.
I WELCOMED A SECOND CHILD, LUCY;
a
.
WHEN YOU HAVE -- DIDN'T THINGS ;
a
IN YOUR HOUSE WHEN YOU WELCOMED;
?
A ABSOLUTELY.
I KIND OF GOT MY ACT TOGETHER.
AT THE END OF THE YEAR THERE WE;
a
-
>> YOU WERE THE MOST, LIKE, ;
a
DRIVEN -- YOU WORK MORE THAN ;
>> YOU WORK PRETTY HARD, TOO.
>> I DO.
BUT YOU HAVE A LEGIT LIKE ;
a
EMPIRE.
YOU HAVE A BOOK IN PRINT.;
a
HOW MANY OF HOURS OF RADIO?
>> TWO CHANTING ON SIRIUS.
>> RIGHT, THE NIGHTTIME SHOW. ;
a
>> BUT, NO.
MY ACT WAS CLEANED UP.
BUT I JUST -- IT WAS KIND OF A
METAPHOR THAT AT THE END OF THE;
a
YEAR WE COULDN'T DRINK ON CNN
AND I HAD KIND OF REINED IN MY
PARTYING --
>> DID YOU EVER THINK WHEN YOU ;
a
WERE A YOUNG GAY KID GROWING UP;
IN CLAYTON, MISSOURI, IN ST.
LOUIS, THAT YOU WOULD BE ABLE T;
a
?
>> DEFINITELY NOT.
>> CHILDREN, A JOB WHERE YOU ;
a
COULD BE OPENLY GAY ON
TELEVISION?
>>> NO.
I REMEMBER WHEN I CAME OUT, I A;
a
SURE YOU HAD A SIMILAR
EXPERIENCE, THAT I REMEMBER MY ;
a
MOM SAYING SHE NEEDED A MINUTE
OR MORE TO MOURN THE LOSS OF TH;
a
LIFE THAT I WAS NOT GOING TO
HAVE.
WHICH IN OUR MINDS AND HER MIND
AT THE TIME INCLUDED ME HAVING
CHILDREN OR HAVING A FAMILY.
>> I REMEMBER YOU WRITING ABOUT;
a
>> RIGHT.
THAT WAS AT THE, YOU KNOW, EARL;
a
THINK IT WAS --
>> I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
>> RIGHT.
IT WAS VERY HOMOPHOBIC. ;
a
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> AND IT REALLY, LIKE, HURT ;
a
?
>> IT DID HURT ME.
I WAS ALSO ON MUSHROOMS THAT
NIGHT.
>> OH?
I DON'T RECALL THAT PART OF YOU;
a
BOOK.
>> SORRY, YES.
BUT ANYWAY, I -- IT DID HURT ME;
a
Y
WORLD THAT I LIVE IN.
AND IT WAS, BY THE WAY, THE ;
a
WORLD THAT WE LIVED IN THEN.;
BUT IT'S INCREDIBLE NOW, AS I
SIT WITH YOU NOW AND WE ;
a
BROADCAST NEW YEAR'S EVE, WHICH;
OLD FRIEND, AND WE NOW HAVE
KIDS.
IT IS A WORLD THAT I NEVER
THOUGHT WOULD EXIST FOR US.;
a
AND WRITING THE BOOK, I THINK
I -- IT'S AMAZING.
I HEARD FROM SO MANY PARENTS
ABOUT HOW RELATABLE IT IS ;
a
HEARING ABOUT THE TRAVAILS OF
TODDLERS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO YOU ARE.;
a
RAISING YOUR KIDS, THE STORIES
ARE VERY UNIVERSAL.
>> WE HAVE THIS HAVE A OF YOU ;
a
DISCUSSING SOMETHING WITH BEN
AND YOUR INSTAGRAM IS,
OBVIOUSLY, VERY FUNNY.
I JUST WANT TO PLAY THIS.;
a
GAVE YOU A COOKIE?
IS THAT WHY YOU ARE CRYING?;
a
WHY?
BECAUSE I TOOK A PIECE OFF FOR
LUCY SO YOU WOULD SHARE WITH ;
a
HER?
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK IT'S NICE FOR YOU TO
SHARE.
THE PIECE I TOOK FOR LUCY IS ;
a
?
--
>> THESE ARE THE JOYS OF
PARENTING.
THESE ARE THE JOYOUS MOMENTS. ;
a
THERE.
ALSO ON INSTAGRAM PEOPLE USUALLY
ONLY SHARE THE PERFECT MOMENTS.
>> YES.
>> SO I LIKE TO SHARE WHAT'S ;
a
REAL AND WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS WE WILL ;
a
NEGLECTED TO COVER TONIGHT IS
THE SCANNED-O-VAL.
THIS IS A BIG NIGHT IN YOUR ;
a
WORLD?
>> IT IS A BIG NIGHT IN THE ;
a
.
IN THE WORLD OF POP CULTURE.;
a
THE FINALE OF "VANDERPUMP RULES"
AND THIS HAS TAKEN OVER POP
CULTURE.
>> I READ ABOUT IN "THE NEW YOR;
a
TIMES," "THE WASHINGTON POST."
>> CNN HAD IT ON THE TICKER, BY;
a
THE WAY.
>> NO.
>> THEY HAD A SECTION ON CNN.COM
FOR REAL.
TO MAKE AN ANALOGY, BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND IT, O;
a
Y
KNEW ALL ALONG.
>> UH-HUH.
>> DID YOU GET THAT?
>> VAGUELY.
>> DO YOU KNOW THE SHOW ;
a
"FRIENDS"?
ARE YOU IN THERE?
>> OKAY.
BUT SO VIEWERS HAVE WATCHED THE
SEASON IN HORROR BECAUSE THEY ;
a
KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON?
>> YES.
>> IT WILL ALL BE REVEALED ;
a
?
>> I SEE.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLE.
I HAVE THE FIRST INTERVIEW WITH;
a
ARIANA TONIGHT.
>> HOT COMPETITION FOR THAT ONE.
>> I KNOW.
>> AND CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR MADE